lunch time in Hong Kong central business
district police firing ever pellets to
disperse protesters bringing traffic in
one of the world's busiest thoroughfares
to a standstill police say this was an
illegal assembly as crowd shouted
pro-democracy slogans and insults at
them not everyone is against them though
I'm from China and I support the police
screams this woman who's from the
mainland
the protesters intended target was Hong
Kong's
Legislative Assembly but a heavy
security presence prevented their
attempts to reach the building inside
legislators were debating a bill that
would punish those who disrespect the
national anthem this is what supporters
of the bill want to stop the booing that
drowned out the March of the volunteers
before a recent football match those
convicted under the planned law would
face a fine of more than six and a half
thousand dollars and up to three years
in jail there were many arrests on
Wednesday with at least one as young as
14 years old detentions that could now
risk university and career prospects
freedom and he comes ahead of a move by
China's Parliament to impose a new
national security law on this city
China's rubber-stamp Parliament the
National People's Congress is expected
to approve draft legislation on Thursday
when more details of the proposed
security law will be known in the
meantime Hong Kong government officials
are trying to ease fears it will be
conducive to the long term stability and
prosperity of Hong Kong and also helpful
to safeguarding the legitimate rights of
Hong Kong people many Hong Kong people
aren't reassured and they now know the
risk for daring to demonstrate their
opposition Adrian Brown al-jazeera
Hong Kong
Benedict Rogers is co-founder and
chairman of Hong Kong watch he says the
movement is likely to keep going until
protesters get what they believe was
promised by the government I don't think
we're seeing the end of the
pro-democracy movement the movement I
think is absolutely as determined as
ever particularly to try to not have
this security law imposed on them
they're not just going to roll over but
we are certainly seeing the end of Hong
Kong's autonomy of one country two
systems and its basic freedoms I think
overall the the weight of responsibility
lies on Carrie Lam and on the central
government in Beijing they have promises
that they should uphold under the terms
of the sino-british joint declaration
and the basic law Hong Kong's
Constitution including a promise albeit
in in vaguely worded terms to introduce
universal suffrage at some stage so the
responsibility is theirs and they have
introduced at various times laws and
measures that have been extremely
repressive and have absolutely provoked
the fury of the people of course there
have been a small minority and I
emphasize small minority of protesters
who have resorted to violent and extreme
action and I don't condone that action
and I think Hong Kong is are at their
best when they protest peacefully but we
should remember that those incidents of
violence have mostly been in response to
police brutality it's usually been the
police that has has acted first and of
course in response to her out of
frustration at a government that just
does not listen to the people